so when you're recording john lennon
let's go back to those days i mean we're
listening to this
[Music]
great record right yeah when you hear
him recording this do you know it's
going to be a hit
well that that song was incredible
because at the time
elton john was massive right and there's
a nice little story about this record
right my boss was having a baby
his wife so he wasn't we weren't working
he wasn't working that week
so john said elton's in town and he's
going to come in and i wanted to sing on
the record so i was terrified
wow you're sitting there with john
lennon elton john's coming in and now
you're the studio engineer
yeah right so i said john
i said to myself every kid that would
walk in every piano play they walked in
in those days would want
ja elton john's piano sound right they
wanted john bonham's drum
sound and they wanted eric clapton's
guitar sound
right you know you need but you need
eric clapton to get that sound right
yeah you got to know what you're doing
well you got to be able to play like so
i didn't know that
so now elton comes in and the first
thing he does is sing and i kind of get
that right and they're singing facing
each other yeah and you had barely
engineered anything
that's exactly right so in a way you got
to be a bit of a [ __ ] artist in the
beginning right like you can't show your
fear
yeah if john lennon did sense you didn't
know what the [ __ ] you were doing
i'm toast you toast yeah so you walk
around like you know what you're doing
that's the beginning
yeah at the very beginning of making
fear a tailwind
instead of a headwind your whole life is
a headwind little league it's a headwind
when i got in there it became a tailwind
i had no choice
so you've got to set up elton's piano
that's right because now he says on the
way out
i want to do a piano uh-oh i said [ __ ]
had you ever set up a piano before
yeah for roy not for elton
no i was so nervous i just took the mics
and i put them where i thought roy put
them to scholar
my boss and i realized at that moment
that the elton's piano sound is in
elton's
hands and the way he bangs it so we
started playing the piano and
banging the [ __ ] out of it and it's if
you could hear it on the record it just
sounded so brilliant
and um so he leaves and as he's leaving
he said i loved when my piano sounds
and john just said that's why we use
them
suddenly you're the hero